How many times should I run the cold and flu rife program before trying a different program when I'm sick?
Okay, so when you're not feeling well, I have mentioned to a good thing to start running as some of the more generic programs like the cold and flu program.
It also depends on if you have a true rife or an atelier aramana. The atelier aramana programs for infections get very specific.
So with the atelier aramana, I was able to create programs that come from the DNA frequencies of the organism.
So if you'll see in the atelier aramana, everybody has a folder that says, you know, it's a folder.
So it says a doctor cutters 11th harmonic kill programs.
And there's, I don't know, 15 or 20 or 25 different specific 11th harmonic kill programs for different pathogens.
So those are all pathogen programs.
But in the I created that program before I changed all the programs to 11th harmonic.
So in the alphabetical list programs of the atelier aramana, you'll see that there's a lot of pathogens that are very specifically very specific bacteria.
That, you know, you might not even be able to pronounce the names, but I did it that way because there's no specific frequencies for those bacteria.
There's a lot of those programs with a specific bacteria and specific viruses are fairly short.
They might only be 10 minutes long.
So you have to run those over and over and over again.
It's because there's only a few known frequencies that are very specific that are taken off of the DNA of that specific pathogen.
So, but it's very specific.
Now, you would only do those if you knew specifically that you were infected with something like that, which most of the time when you don't feel well, you don't know what it is.
Okay, unless you're running down and getting a sputum sample of your cough material and having it analyzed and a laboratory that they're telling you exactly what bacterial infection is or viral infection.
It is you're not knowing that.
So then it's better to run the cold and clue programs or you can get this is with the true right or the atelier aramana.
There's strip programs are strip and staff programs are there's different cold and flu programs different you know flu on coming different strip strap you know staff type programs that are more generic and there's just a bacterial program.
So, if you don't know what it is that you're infected with, you're just going to have to run some of those.
So, for instance, our whole family was infected with a really bad cold with a really bad flu type thing that just really wiped out literally everybody in the family.
And we were experimenting with different programs because everybody was so sick.
So, it's difficult to know unless you get tested exactly what you're dealing with.
Is it a strap A? Is it a strap B? Is it a is it some sort of weird virus?
You just don't know so you're just going to have to run the different programs.
Now again, if you're dealing with a sickness like that, I suggest you run it 24 seven if you can so you're going to have to play with different programs see if you notice one that makes you feel better.
So, you know, I just I do believe that in this day and age that we live in there's a lot of infections that are maybe altered in some laboratory somewhere.
So, it makes it more viral or that it's going to go around virulent, I mean, and it can make it more harmful to us as humans.
So, it's not just your regular average blue anymore.
It's it's something that is created to be more virulent and more be more damaging.
So, you're going to have to play with some different frequencies to find out which one will work best for you.
I wish I had just a more perfect answer for that, but I don't.
You're just going to have to run different frequencies as much as you possibly can.